Lamento decirlo pero la era de los
grandes conflictos parece estar de
vuelta desde la invasión rusa de Ucrania
hasta la guerra urbana en gaza pasando
por la tensión Al rojo vivo en el alto
kabaj La amenaza de invasión de Taiwán o
las inacabables escaramuzas golpes de
estado y batallas que en África
encontramos por todas partes queridos
amigos el mundo parece en llamas sí no
nos vendría mal una sesión de meditación
colectiva pero ya sabéis lo que se dice
por ahí el dinero es el nervio de la
guerra esta frase que comúnmente se le
atribuye al filósofo y político Romano
cicerón se explica hoy con noticias como
esta ayuda estadounidense Israel y
Ucrania Esto es lo que contiene el
paquete de seguridad Nacional de 105000
millones de dólares solicitado por biden
linken en Ucrania Estados Unidos anuncia
1000 millones de dólares en ayuda
militar y civil Estados Unidos anuncia
un paquete de ayuda militar para Taiwán
por valor de 345 millones de dólares y
desde luego si hay un país que está a
top con los tambores de la guerra este
es claramente Estados Unidos Porque si
las armas fuesen música no os quepa la
menor duda de que Estados Unidos sería
el DJ principal de esta salvaje
macrofiesta para que os hagáis una idea
en los últimos 4 años las exportaciones
militares del Tío Sam han representado
el 40% de todo el armamento
comercializado en todo el
planeta el flujo de armamento de Estados
Unidos al resto del mundo es dos veces
más grande que el de Rusia y multi por
hasta ocho veces la cuota de Mercado de
China está claro que si algo que saben
hacer los americanos es fabricar armas
en eso América es imbatible Claro que
además de vender armas Estados Unidos
también está sosteniendo o apoyando
varios esfuerzos de guerra digamos que
en esta ocasión la superpotencia
norteaméricana está librando guerras Sin
poner un solo hombre en el campo de
batalla Estados Unidos está financiera y
operativamente metido hasta el cuello en
al menos tres zonas calientes primero no
hace falta que os lo lo diga en Ucrania
segundo en el estrecho de Taiwán y
tercero en Israel el resultado es que el
despacho oval o casi Mejor dicho la olla
oval está hoy sometida a una presión
geopolítica enorme porque cada una a su
manera estas tres áreas calientes
necesitan y lo digo porque ellos mismos
lo piden la asistencia económica y
militar del Tío Sam y es por eso que
aquí en visual politic nos hemos hecho
unas cuantas preguntas cómo está Estados
Unidos sosteniendo estos tres frentes
bélicos al mismo tiempo será el gigante
norteamericano capaz de financiar estas
campañas qué coste están teniendo
exactamente Pues todo esto y más lo
vamos a ver a continuación cinturones
listos y despeguemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
cada vez que salta una chispa en el
mundo Lo raro es que no encontremos a
los Estados Unidos metidos de por medio
es lo que muchos llaman la ilusión de
creerse la policía del mundo una especie
de en el salvaje oeste sea como sea la
cuestión es que hoy por hoy las fuerzas
armadas de Estados Unidos son las únicas
capaces de llevar a cabo de forma
razonablemente rápida amplios
despliegues de tropas y material en
prácticamente cualquier Rincón perdido
del mundo y lógicamente esa capacidad
logística les da una influencia
desmedida por un lado les permite poder
intervenir directamente en cualquier
conflicto por otro les permite dar apoyo
a cualquier gobierno extranjero en
cualquier momento sin ir más lejos la
Guerra de Ucrania ha sido un buen
ejemplo pensadlo bien El Tío Sam logró
entregar de forma rápida una enorme
cantidad de armas municiones y
provisiones de todo tipo al ejército
ucraniano en plena ofensiva rusa por
supuesto toda esta capacidad no se ha
creado de la noche a la mañana más bien
ha sido un objetivo desde los años 40
cuando el presidente Franklin Delano
Roosevelt impulsó la idea de que Estados
Unidos tenía que convertirse en el
arsenal de la Democracia una idea que en
mayor o menor medida han mantenido hasta
la fecha prácticamente todos los
presidentes
[Música]
estadounidenses Ai System of
International Security the free people
have no Choice but to Keep their
Arms we most of the money most of the
arms most of the men to help other
nations defend their fre the strength of
Our National must rested so that we can
purs pros and Peace And fre maintaining
Our commitment
en general tanto para los demócratas
como para los republicanos esto ha sido
siempre una prioridad en cierta forma
podríamos decir que de Roosevelt a biden
Y mira que ha llovido la receta de la
influencia mundial norteamericana no ha
cambiado mucho un poco de diplomacia un
montón de armas y una pizca de puedo
estar en tu casa antes que una pizza y
si no que se lo digan a Noriega por
supuesto todo esto se ha traducido en un
multim millonario gasto militar Y
también en la financiación de un montón
de conflictos a lo largo y ancho del
mundo Pues bien El caso es que para
llevar a cabo esta última misión el
gobierno norteamericano tiene reglas que
se tienen que cumplir a la hora de
entregar suministros militares a otro
país hablamos sobre todo de la ley de
asistencia extranjera esta ley le
permite al gobierno de los Estados
Unidos proporcionar asistencia
financiera y material incluida
asistencia militar a países extranjeros
con el fin de promover lógicamente sus
propios intereses hermanitas de la
Caridad no son ahora bien la pregunta es
cómo se lleva a cabo esta asistencia
pues amigos vamos a encontrar
fundamentalmente tres vías primero
mediante lo que se conoce como las
ventas militares extranjeras mediante
este procedimiento Estados Unidos
autoriza la venta de equipos sensibles a
países aliados es decir hablamos de
transacciones comerciales de pedidos a
fábrica pero que son intermediados por
el Departamento de defensa en segundo
lugar tenemos lo que se conoce como la
financiación militar exterior en este
caso Estados Unidos de acuerdo a Los
criterios del departamento de estado
financia o subvenciona directamente la
compra de equipos militares
norteamericanos nuevos a terceros países
y En tercer lugar está la autoridad
presidencial para La retirada de
recursos esto permite la transferencia
directa de equipo militar del propio
stock norteamericano si el presidente
determina e informa al congreso de que
existe una emergencia imprevista que
requi asist militar inmediata a un país
extranjero Y el requisito de emergencia
no puede cumplirse bajo la autoridad de
la ley de control de exportaciones o
cualquier otra ley excepto esta sección
podrá Ordenar el retiro de artículos de
defensa de las existencias del
departamento de defensa por un valor
agregado que no exceda los 100 millones
de dólares en cualquier año fiscal
seguramente ya os habéis dado cuenta de
que la cifra se queda algo corta por
ponerlo en perspectiva harían falta 40
años de ese presupuesto para poder
construir los dos nuevos airf One Bueno
pues tiene trampa La ley es antigua por
eso desde 1960 se han aprobado cerca de
20 enmiendas para modificar los techos
de transferencia en 2022 esta cifra fue
de 11,000 millones de
dó El caso amigos es que la distinción
entre las ventas militares extranjeras
la financiación militar exterior y la
transferencia directa no es un simple
tecnicismo sino que como vamos a ver es
algo que ha generado un debate cada vez
más caliente en Washington los
conflictos militares cada vez más
numerosos están obligando a Washington a
reorganizar sus apuestas por eso la
pregunta es qué exigencias suponen hoy
Ucrania Israel y Taiwán para la
asistencia militar norteamericana está
la Casa Blanca agobiada por las
tensiones militares que se están
produciendo pues queridos amigos amigas
aquí tendremos que ir Punto por punto
porque lo cierto Es que cada carpeta que
llega a manos de biden y sus asesores
trae consigo distintos dolores de cabeza
empecemos si os parece por el lejano
Oriente
atentos Taiwán el precio de la disuasión
[Música]
los mares de China han sido la prioridad
número uno para el departamento de
estado en materia de disuasión militar
durante la última década irónicamente es
el único espacio donde al menos hoy por
hoy los intereses norteamericanos
todavía no están en medio de un
conflicto activo en este caso la
distribución y asignación de
equipamiento militar a Taiwán es muy
distinta a la cooperación con Ucrania e
Israel empezando en primer lugar porque
la isla no es en sí misma un país
independiente O al menos no lo es para
Pekín ni formalmente para Estados Unidos
para el régimen de shiin Pin la relación
entre Estados Unidos y Taiwán es algo
así como la relación entre un país
soberano y una provincia china esto
obliga a los norteamericanos a llevar a
cabo toda una ingeniería legal a la hora
de asignar fondos y equipos militares
luego en segundo lugar el teatro de
operaciones del estrecho de Taiwán es un
único Ya que en este caso Hablamos de
una situación de guerra insular donde la
Marina y la fuerza aérea resultan
absolutamente claves en contraste por
ejemplo con la utilidad que tiene la
Infantería de tierra en Las Guerras de
Israel y Ucrania pero bien la cuestión
es que desde
1979 Estados Unidos está obligado a
poner y cito literalmente a disposición
de Taiwán los artículos de defensa y los
servicios de defensa en la cantidad que
sea necesaria para permitir que Taiwán
mantenga suficientes capac idades de
autodefensa esto lo dice expresamente La
Ley de relaciones con Taiwán que
promulgó el entonces presidente Jimmy
Carter desde entonces se ha orientado la
cooperación militar con Taiwán mediante
las ventas militares extranjeras es
decir Taiwán es un país relativamente
rico que puede pagar sus compras de
armamento lo que necesita sobre todo es
poder acceder a equipos avanzados
durante décadas las ventas de armas
estadounidenses a Taiwán han sido la
contribución más visible de Estados
Unidos a las capacidades de defensa de
Taiwán en el periodo 2020-2022 Taiwán
fue el mayor comprador de ventas
militares extranjeras de Estados Unidos
y fue el cuarto mayor comprador entre
1950 y 2022 sin embargo en los últimos
años esta forma de llevar a cabo la
cooperación con Taiwán ha empezado a
generar muchísimas dudas sobre su
eficacia principalmente por dos
[Música]
motivos en primer lugar existe un
problema de tiempos los pedidos se
demoran años y años en entr
recientemente se reveló que se estaban
preparando ventas potenciales por valor
de 19,000 millones de dólares y algunas
partidas se remontaban a 2016 este largo
cronograma es incompatible con una
sensación inmediata de amenaza armar a
Taiwán de esta forma implica que pueden
pasar años y años Hasta que el
equipamiento se entrega y empieza a
estar operativo por ejemplo desde 2019
Estados Unidos está gestionando la
compra de más de 60 aviones f16
destinados a las fuerzas aéreas de
Taiwán la cuestión es que el logit
Martin en septiembre de 2023 dijo que
estaba redoblando sus esfuerzos para
producir hacia finales de 2025 cerca de
cuatro aviones f16 por mes Claro si
tenemos en cuenta que esta empresa
también tiene que lidiar con las compras
de otros países como Eslovaquia o barin
el flujo de cazas hacia Taiwán es más
lento que un funcionario un viernes por
la tarde y eso no es
todo por otro lado una potencial guerra
en el estrecho de Taiwán exigiría llevar
a cabo un despliegue logístico sin
precedentes el esfuerzo tendría que
focalizarse en evitar que la isla fuese
bloqueada por la armada china
garantizando en todo momento una línea
de suministro constante con los aliados
occidentales al tiempo que se evite o se
derrote cualquier intento de desembarco
Enemigo El problema que para cumplir
estos objetivos hacen falta unas
capacidades que no concuerdan bien con
el equipamiento que está comprando el
ejército taiwanés es algo de lo que ya
os hemos hablado aquí en visual politic
Taiwán necesita una nueva estrategia de
de defensa para tratar con china los
expertos estadounidenses critican a
Taiwán por gastar demasiado en artículos
caros en lugar de comprar y construir
grandes barcos aviones y tanques que
pueden ser fácilmente inutilizados por
los misiles chinos dicen que Taiwán
debería acumular reservas de municiones
y comprar armas más baratas y móviles la
defensa del hombre de paja está
consumiendo al ejército de Taiwán Taiwán
debería evaluar su fuerza actual y todas
las inversiones futuras una gran parte
de su presupuesto de seguridad se dedica
a capacidades que no sobrevivirán a los
primeros minutos de una guerra o que
ofrecen muy poca capacidad para frenar
una invasión ahora tras la experiencia
de Ucrania Washington ha comenzado a
tomarse mucho más en serio la defensa de
Taiwán no sea que la falta de disuasión
por no estar preparados termine
provocando una invasión que obligue a
Estados Unidos a entrar en guerra
precisamente por eso el pasado mes de
septiembre de 2023 biden notificó al
congreso que haría uso de Su autoridad
presidencial para cambiar parcialmente
el modelo de asistencia militar a la
isla de esta forma la administración
biden hará entregas directas de equipos
militares de los propios stock de las
fuerzas armadas de Estados Unidos esto
además de agilizar algunas entregas
críticas les dará a los norteamericanos
una enorme potestad para decidir qué se
envía al estrecho y con ello influir en
la estrategia taiwanesa La pregunta es
hasta qué punto ha tenido algo que ver
la experiencia de la guerra en Ucrania
Pues atentos porque la vinculación con
ki puede haber sido el punto de
inflexión a la hora de poner a Taiwán en
el top uno de
[Música]
prioridades Ucrania cuando las patatas
queman creo que para nadie es un secreto
que tras la invasión rusa de Ucrania
Estados Unidos ha enviado una enorme
cantidad de armas hacia Europa hablamos
del mayor plan de asistencia en el viejo
continente desde el Plan Marshall desde
que estalló el conflicto en febrero del
año pasado Estados Unidos ha destinado
más de 75,000 millones de dólares en
asistencia al gobierno ucraniano
lógicamente una parte muy importante de
toda esta enorme ayuda se utilizado para
enviar una gigantesca cantidad de armas
y munición sin embargo la solidaridad
norteamericana podría no ser ilimitada
muchos republicanos del ala trumpista
consideran que la ayuda a ki ha sido
excesiva la ayuda ucraniana entred dicho
Johnson quiere retirarla del proyecto de
ley de ayuda a Israel la administración
biden quiere que el congreso apruebe
61,000 millones de dólares más para
Ucrania sí 61,000 millones es mucho
dinero pero realmente no es una cantidad
tan importante al menos para la
gigantesca economía
norteamericana en cierta forma la Guerra
de Ucrania está siendo relativamente
barata sobre todo si tenemos en cuenta
los resultados que está dando esta ayuda
y ojo no lo decimos nosotros sino el
propio líder republicano del senado
Mitch mcconnel
fijaos
[Música]
y en términos de pragmatismo político
tiene razón cuesta decirlo pero si
hablamos de Real politic a Estados
Unidos esta guerra le está saliendo
baratísima en términos de pib Apenas ha
supuesto un gasto del
0,18 en equipos militares y del
0,3 en total Pero entonces Por qué
tantos republicanos parecen tener tantos
problemas pues a ver supuestamente las
quejas no estarían directamente
vinculadas a la ayuda militar en sí sino
a las condiciones con las que se
envía y Es que veréis desde el primer
día biden ha hecho uso de la autoridad
presidencial y del programa de
financiamiento militar extranjero para
abordar la entrega de armas a Ucrania lo
que en la práctica resulta bastante
lógico ya que o se enviaban armas a toda
pastilla o Rusia habría terminado
saliéndose con la suya El problema es
que esto ha hecho que la transparencia
no sea tan grande hay poca información
sobre fletes entregas y proveedores en
cierto modo la ayuda se ha entregado
bajo una especie de paragua gris que los
republicanos han criticado duramente
Claro que pensad un momento teniendo en
cuenta la guerra que se estaba liberando
quizás tampoco habrá sido muy lógico que
Estados Unidos anunciara públicamente y
con todo detalle las entregas realizadas
luego otra crítica es que las
transferencias están reduciendo el stock
de armas del propio ejército
norteamericano en una cantidad que dados
los niveles de producción actuales de la
industria militar norteamericana puede
tardar bastante en reponerse sea como
sea el caso es que esta falta de
transparencia y sobre todo la crispación
política junto con el agotamiento por
una guerra que ya se alarga más de la
cuenta ha hecho que los norteamericanos
cada vez apoyen menos sobre todo los
republicanos y los independientes que se
mantenga la cooperación con Ucrania por
supuesto por sí mismo esto supone otro
quebradero más de de cabeza para el
gobierno de biden a las puertas de un
nuevo año electoral Pero ha visto el
caso de Ucrania Hacia dónde apunta el
papel de Estados Unidos en la guerra de
gaza está suponiendo este conflicto una
especie de tarta envenenada para la
administración biden
[Música]
atentos Israel lo que
faltaba Como dice el dicho éramos pocos
y parió la abuela si las carpetas y las
reuniones en el pentágono ya no daban
abasto con las demandas de taipei y kif
el ataque de jamas a Israel del pasado 7
de octubre ha sido la gota que ha
colmado el
baso el secretario de estado Anthony
blinken No solo tiene que lidiar ahora
con la nueva cooperación con Taiwán y la
creciente tensión que se vive en torno a
una hipotética invasión china sino
también con La amenaza republicana de
bloquear los fondos a Ucrania y lo que
el Primer Ministro Benjamin netanyahu ha
calificado como la Segunda Guerra de
Independencia de Israel ahora bien al
menos en este caso el camino está mejor
trazado Y es que Estados Unidos e Israel
son aliados muy estrechos y desde
noviembre de 1983 opera de hecho un
grupo Conjunto político militar que
anualmente diseña y consensua los
programas de asistencia entre ambos
países de hecho Israel es el país que
más excedentes militares ha recibido de
Estados Unidos en la última década muy
pero muy por encima de las capacidades
transferidas bajo esta modalidad a
Taiwán o Ucrania además según
información oficial hasta octubre de
este 2023 Estados Unidos tenía con
Israel casi 600 contratos vinculados a
los aviones de combate f35 helicópteros
de carga pesada
ch53k aviones tierna de reabastecimiento
kc4 6a y municiones guiadas de precisión
muchos de estos contratos son pagados
por Estados Unidos de hecho para que os
hagáis una idea se estima que desde
1948 Estados Unidos ha proporcionado a
Israel más de 130,000 millones de dólar
en ayuda bilateral si tenemos en cuenta
la inflación hablamos de unos
260,000 millones de dólares de hoy pero
claro eso no es
[Aplausos]
todo como ya os hemos contado aquí en
visual politic el riesgo de que se
termine desarrollando un conflicto a
mayor escala con hezbolá Siria o incluso
Irán ha hecho que la administración
biden redoble sus esfuerzos enviando
directamente un montón de efectivos
militares y barcos a la zona e
incrementando también la asistencia
militar a Israel hablamos de un paquete
adicional de ayuda de al menos 14,000
millones de dólares así que ya lo veis
estos son los tres conflictos más
calientes o más fríos en los que
Washington está metido hasta el cuello
hacía mucho tiempo que el entramado
militar norteamericano no se veía
sometido a tanta presión en términos de
stock y arsenales de munición y armas La
pregunta es hasta qué punto pensáis que
Estados Unidos debe apoyar a Taiwán
Ucrania e Israel cuál sería vuestro
orden de prioridad podéis dejarnos
vuestras impresiones en los comentarios
y habramos debate y ahora si este vídeo
te ha resultado interesante No olvides
darle al botón de like y suscribirte a
visual politic si es que aún no lo has
hecho un saludo y hasta la
[Música]
próxima